you mentioned that there's someone named
richard dodie who is driven mad
do you mind expanding on that or
expatiating yeah that that's a deep dive
that people will need to
really look into but no richard dodie
did not go mad
there's a guy in paul benowitz that this
was a a situation where the united
states government
put disinformations into the ufo field
uh one of the guys involved he's a
friend paul
dennowitz uh benowitz with a ben nowitz
yeah this is a guy named rick dodie
who's a friend of mine
i like rick people vilify him and
they're so angry i'm friends with him
he's a good guy he was okay so who's
rick and who's paul and what happened to
them
rick dodi was was paid to disinform
the american public about ufos by
infiltrating
the ufo field and spreading
disinformation
and in one of his jobs doing this there
was an individual
named paul benowitz who was being fed
the disinformation and why it's so
controversial
is because paul benowitz uh went crazy
you know in some states because of the
you know rick dodi playing with his mind
and his emotions but
in reality paul had had a breakdown
prior
paul was not fully hinged so that's a
that's a very famous case in ufo
lore about the united states military
manipulating the beliefs of people
within the ufo field which has happened
from time to time
rick worked for the government and paul
was just someone who was interested in
or maybe he's a ufologist some people
call them yeah he was a very brilliant
scientist
who worked near manzano weapons storage
area out in
new mexico and he was filming things on
a classified base from his home
and they were rick paul what's up paul
was filming
okay paul was and rick was tasked with
disinforming
the ufo public and paul and a couple
other people
researchers it happens all the time
people that research ufos
you you get hit with with people trying
to convince you of something happens to
me
all the time i get evidence that's too
good to be true i get photographs
documents and i never publish it because
these people are [ __ ] with me
you think that they're government spies
or government agents
i i don't know of who they work for
but yeah certainly there i have um
gotten information that is feels too
good to be true
and when i dig deeper and deeper i'm not
going to fall for it yeah
i don't know who's orchestrating it yeah
and rick's role at the government was
what
was he a part of the cia or fbi or what
yeah that's uh i think it was osi
office's special investigation for the
army i i don't recall
specifically uh but he has done a lot of
counter intelligence and intelligence
work for the army
was this disinformation part of project
blue book or was this just
a separate task yeah it was separate
project blue book
officially ended in 1969 right and there
was you know a certain number of cases
they were unresolved and uh
yes but there have been active programs
about ufos since then